[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur verließ welt der
muttertag kommt und ich habe mir gedacht
machen wir doch dieses jahr einen
blumentopf halt noch nicht beißen doch
für die oma gefällt er dir ja glaub so
das ist ein kuchen und jetzt auch keinen
kuchen das ist eine echte blume was ist
das ist echt oder einen kuchen
okay er hat mich durchschaut
wahrscheinlich riecht sie die leckeren
schoko kekse da am rand manchmal und das
ist auch eine richtig tolle torte die
ihr zum muttertag vorbereiten könnt dann
eure mama oder oma opa schwester egal
wie
damit beschränken können damit man eine
schokoladentorte weil es einfach oft ich
wirklich sehr am ehrte erinnert und hier
oben haben wir einfach schöne bunte
blumen gemischt und die bekommt dann
meine mama ich wann geht es zuerst
einmal anhört dem teig und dafür zeige
ich euch die zutaten für den teig
verwende ich feiere 200 gramm zucker
eine prise salz etwas war den extrakt
und einen tonkabohne 200 gramm
sonnenblumenöl 200 gramm naturjoghurt
300 gramm mehl 2 teelöffel backpulver
und 100 gramm mandeln die werden gleich
noch gemahlen
das ist übrigens eine lockere teig für
motiv torten den ich bereits in meinem
basics drin habt also jetzt zuerst die
eier in eine rührschüssel geben dann den
zucker dazu etwas salz und relax trucks
eine prise tonkabohne die richtig super
lecker und jetzt für etwa fünf bis zehn
minuten richtig schaurig verrühren und
ich werde die zwischenzeit nutzen der
ofen ist schon vorgeheizt und ich werde
zwischen zeit nutzen und die mandeln
fein mahlen
vielleicht ist euch aufgefallen aber die
schokolade fehlten gucken aber kein
problem
ich nehme einfach 50 gramm mehl raus und
macht 50 kompakt aber es muss ich kacke
aufhören weil vergessen aber gratis
aufgefallen ich dachte er kennt das
stimmt nicht
naja besser jetzt als später soll jetzt
aber jetzt haben wir erst richtig da
muss ich jetzt einfach noch das
backpulver rein
die trockenen zutaten für mich immer
vorher gerne damit sie sich einfach
schön verbinden und dem teig nicht
lumpen und da muss man insgesamt den
teig später eben kürzer rühren und nicht
so lange
es gebe ich hier das öl zum teig und den
joghurt so gut macht den teig ich schön
saftig
jetzt gibt ein ring
das mehl klumpp nicht aber dass kakao
und war das klingt immer so also werde
ich jetzt trockenen zutaten noch 7
[Musik]
dann noch die gemahlenen mandeln dazu
und die x ich immer gerne selber weil
sie so noch ihr volles aroma haben wir
jetzt wirklich nur ganz kurz unternehmen
bis alles verbunden ist
ich habe ich jetzt zwei baken
vorbereitet das ganze wieder ein tontopf
und wird so ein bisschen komisch zu
laufen und den durchmesser sehe ich hier
am rand ganz gut da steht ja 18 drauf
ich mache jetzt beide 18 groß dann ist
die torte nämlich schön hoch und wird
nicht so weit
und dann kann ich sie immer noch zu
schneiden jetzt kommt der teig in den
backofen und wird gebacken und in der
zwischenzeit kann ich schon ein paar
blüten herstellen aber erstmal hinter
waschen
[Musik]
für die blüten könnte jetzt entweder von
dor nehmen oder zum beispiel marzipan
mit smart fan weil die ganze torte dann
auch mit marzipan bedeckt wird
hier habe ich jetzt drei farben 72 plus
weiß rot hellblau und weiß und damit dem
markt an masse schon fest wird nehme ich
einfach noch ein bisschen blüten passte
damit die blüten auch schön und schnell
ihre form behalten also jetzt einfach in
euren lieblings farben mischen ich werde
zell blau und rot mission mit etwas
weißer blüten passte dann bekomme ich
eine flieder und dann mache ich noch ein
rosé traum denke ich
und wer möchte kann gerne noch verpasste
nehmen um die masse einzuwerben
hier habe ich meine vier farben gemischt
richtig schön ich finde sie passen auch
super zusammen
ok weiß habe ich nicht gemacht das war
und jetzt nehme ich einfach ein bisschen
becker stärke und rolle die masse schön
dünn aus und marzipan und von dort
unterscheidet sich natürlich von land
ist einfach nur süß schmeckt nach zucker
marzipan schmeckt eben richtig schön
nach mandeln aber natürlich hat von land
andere eigenschaften als marzahn weil es
einfach mehr zucker enthält
aber dieser mann ist wirklich super man
kann ganz toll ausrollen ist auch
elastisch also elastischer als normales
marzipan und ich finde man kann super
einfärben und wirklichkeit verarbeiten
sie könnten selbst entscheiden möchtet
ihr jetzt eine marzipantorte machen oder
eine vom land orte ich mach das jetzt
auch gar nicht zu dünn sondern etwa
einen millimeter dick habe jetzt hier
verschiedene blumen ausstecher blumen
und blüten und da könnte jetzt einfach
die formen wählen die euch am besten
gefallen
[Musik]
dann habe ich hier solche eierschalen
die sind bei meinem kühlschrank direkt
mitgeliefert worden
da lege ich dir jetzt rein dann trocknen
sie so ein bisschen dreidimensional und
der kleine aus sicht der hat hier so
einen auswurf wenn ihr damit auf eine
schau matte geht könnt ihr den so ein
bisschen prägen
dabei kommt es in der mitte so ein
kleines pünktchen
[Musik]
einige blumen lasse ich jetzt auch hier
auf dem löffel trocknen und wenn ihr
möchtet könnt ja auch mal zwei
übereinander setzen so sind sie
dreidimensionaler und wer hat lust drauf
hat und auch perl daheim hat kam zb
zuckerperlen und demeter kleben einfach
mit es beim kleber
[Musik]
ein bisschen marzipan fertig jetzt noch
grün ein rolls aus und sticht auch
kleine blätter aus und die blätter die
können ja dann auf papier trocknen
lassen das backpapier einfach so ein
bisschen letzter kumpel papier kann ich
ja dann wieder verwenden und so bekommt
auch eine schöne struktur beim trocknen
der kuchen ist jetzt abgekühlt und ich
habe ihn einfach in den kühlschrank
gestellt damit es nicht gleich besser zu
schneiden lässt jetzt mache ich eine
creme und zwar eines mit buttercreme das
ist eine buttercreme basierend auf
eiweiß und butter die butter schmeckt
man echt nicht raus und ich mache auch
eine schoko creme daraus dass die creme
ist wirklich super super lecker sehr
locker und ich weiß viele mögen
buttercreme nicht aber probiert es doch
gerne mal aus ich sage ich mal die
zutaten für die buttercreme verwende ich
125 gramm eiweiß 220 gramm zucker eine
prise salz etwas von den extrakt 360
gramm weiche butter 80 gramm puderzucker
und 200 gramm butter schokolade auf
meinem blog da gibt's schon das
grundrezept das heißt da könnt ihr es
euch nochmal in ganzer ausführlichkeit
abschauen
ich nehme jetzt zuerst das eiweiß denn
zucker salz und dass man den extrakt und
das ganze wird erwärmt über dem heißen
wasserbad oder wenn in der
küchenmaschine habt mit temperatur auch
gerne darin auf 70 grad erhitzt und dann
zehn minuten lang geschlagen so werden
alle keime getötet und das eiweiß wird
richtig schön fest und stabil
[Musik]
jetzt gibts die sicherheitsfunktion dh
die maschine stellt jetzt automatisch
die geschwindigkeit herunter sobald 60
grad erreicht sind damit einfach keine
heißen machen aus dem kopf heraus
spritzen und dann drückt ihr einfach auf
die rote taste so erhöht sich die
geschwindigkeit wieder und die maschine
weiß einfach okay da ist jemand dabei
und hat kontrolle über das gerät nach
zehn minuten könnt ihr dann die hitze
herunter stellen einfach ausschalten und
die masse dann schön kalt rühren und in
der zwischenzeit kann ich die butter mit
dem puderzucker schönen weiß cremig
verrühren
die eier massa ist jetzt kalt gerührt
die butter ist weil ich schaue mich um
die schokolade geschmolzen
jetzt wird einfach alles miteinander
verrührt
[Musik]
lecker guckt euch mal diese krämer jetzt
wo ich den kuchen aus dem kühlschrank im
anklamer die torte schon film den kalten
tortenboden den kann ich jetzt durch
schneiden am besten jeweils ein bis zwei
mal schöne dünne böten
das nehme ich den torten drehteller und
ein garagen wort das lege ich jetzt hin
als unterlage dann kommt da ein bisschen
was von der creme drauf damit der kuchen
boden auch nicht verrutscht
ich nehme jetzt das untere stück links
hier drauf und dann könnt ihr gerne
tortenböden die sind zwar heftig aber
ihr könnt sie gern noch automatisieren
mit kaffee zum beispiel oder nimmt ein
likör dann ein kleines bisschen von der
buttercreme
und so wird jetzt die komplette torte
gefüllt bis die tortenböden aufgebracht
wird
und hier schneide ich jetzt oben ganz
vorsichtig noch den deckel weg
das brauche ich später nämlich noch zu
zerbröseln
[Musik]
die torte stelle ich jetzt in den
kühlschrank damit die buttercreme schon
fest wird die buttercreme kann nicht so
lange bei raumtemperatur lagern
ihr könnt doch gerne ein bisschen mehr
buttercreme für die füllung nehmen ich
mag es aber gleich so dass ich die
buttercreme einfach für außen benutze
damit ich außen wirklich einen schönen
glatten rand bekommen also jetzt kühl
stellen klasse zurecht schneiden
der kuchen ist jetzt richtig schön kalt
muss zugeben ich habe es einfach gemacht
werden kurz eingefroren
so geht's schneller jetzt nehmt ihr euch
am besten einen teller der so ein
bisschen kleiner ist als der kuchen
denn ich möchte ja dass der blutdruck so
leicht chronisch so läuft und dann habe
ich ja dass garagen bord jetzt nehme ich
ein messer und schneidet praktisch von
oben nach unten das ganze schräg zu
[Musik]
und noch einen kanal ching bord nehmen
zum drehen
denn jetzt ist der blumentopf erst
richtig rum jetzt aufpassen mit der
buttercreme noch nach der form schauen
das kriege ich später ausgeglichen
jetzt nehme ich einfach die torten creme
von der ich ja noch ein bisschen was
übrig habe und bestreichen die torte
zuerst mit der ersten schicht die findet
nämlich hier diese kleinen krümel sind
am rand
diese kuchen krümelchen und dann stelle
ich sie in den kühlschrank und lasse da
einfach abgedeckt über nacht stehen und
dekoriere morgen dann die torte fertig
[Musik]
die torte ist jetzt richtig schön durch
gekühlt und jetzt bestreite ich sie noch
mal schön mit der buttercreme
[Musik]
so ist jetzt auch ich habe ein bisschen
creme noch übrig das aber gar nicht
schlimm die werde ich nämlich einfrieren
und kann sie dann später wieder
auftauchen wenn ich sie brauche und
einfach wieder mit dem mixer aufschlagen
es ist auch immer ganz gut wenn man ein
bisschen mehr creme übrig hat also
lieber ein bisschen zu viel als zu wenig
denn wenn ihr die torte ein bisschen
üppiger fühlt als ich dann fehlt euch
einfach also ist die menge echt super
der rand gefällt mir jetzt richtig gut
und hier oben baue ich jetzt so eine
kleine kugel damit die erde die
blumenerde hier gleichauf sitzen kann
und das ganze dreidimensionaler aussieht
also so viel creme habe ich nicht gar
nicht übrig die menge ist echt und wenn
die torte jetzt gleich glatt gestrichen
ist stelle ich dir nochmal in den
kühlschrank für etwa eine halbe stunde
so wird sie noch mal richtig schön kalt
und ich kann schon mal die masse
vorbereiten
hier habe ich jetzt drei päckchen weißen
marzipan schön weich geknetet vielleicht
hat auch schon super weich und den
fertig jetzt ein bisschen ein mit den
resten also ich mache so einem hellen
ton
ich gucke jetzt einfach mal was
rauskommt bisschen lila bisschen blau
bisschen rot gleich nämlich noch etwas
geld dazu
[Musik]
das habe ich hier eine schöne pastellige
farben terrakotta wird auch gut passen
aber ich glaub für die tat ist ein
bisschen zu extrem
daher lieber eine helle farbe jetzt
länglich ausrollen
denn das ganze wird jetzt drum herum
gelegt also ein langes band damit schön
gleichmäßig wird detail kölzer
und ich sehe jetzt auf das smartphone
lässt sich echt super aus rollen wie vom
land eigentlich wenn ich etwas back
trance play für die torte damit die
marzipan masse hält und gerade
abschneiden aber auf das silikon mathe
immer mit einem stumpfen messer jetzt
muss ich kurz die höhe einer torte also
werde ich jetzt hier das ganze 11,5 oder
12 cm bereit schneiden damit so ein
bisschen oben überstellt nicht mal 12
jetzt mit becker sterkel streuen damit
es nicht klebt das hier aufräumen
die täter setzen und erproben
[Musik]
erst mal grob wegschneiden und stand da
hinten ein messer ein schönes scharfes
messer ansetzen und eine gerade carter
wegschneiden das wird dann sowieso der
rückseite
[Musik]
jetzt nämlich von land kletter und kann
die torte noch mal schön glätten und ihr
seht die bäcker stärke lässt sich dann
später ganz einfach mit dem pinsel
wieder entfernen
[Musik]
die torte jetzt erstmal in den
kühlschrank damit alles wieder schön
fest werden kann
räume hier kurz auf und macht noch ein
schönes blumenbild ich habe jetzt noch
die übrigen blüten passte und daraus
mache ich jetzt ein blumen schildes wird
dann schön in die torte und reingesteckt
und da kann man dann auch richtig schön
eine botschaft draufschreiben also ich
werde jetzt erstmal zurechtschneiden und
ich habe hier einen holzspieß einmal ein
schaustück spießt und einmal in echt gut
kuchen nebel und kuchen spiels dagegen
schon
und da werde ich das dann gleich
drumherum wickeln und dann hebt es oder
dran
das heißt zu gross will ich jetzt auch
nicht machen
also schön zurecht schneiden
ich mache das dann so wie bei diesem
schild dass dann praktisch der holzspieß
dazwischen kommt also betrifft ich jetzt
schon mal und dafür nehme ich jetzt
einfach die farbstifte das ist ein
lebensmittel stifter keine echten pilz
stiftet und wer vorhat damit so ein
bisschen im used-look bekommt auch
nochmal mit pulver bestreichen also
bisschen braun bisschen orange zu sitzen
bislang aus
[Musik]
kann ich das beschriftete etikett
aneinander kleben das hier ist die
rückseite dies auch etwas kleiner
geschnitten damit vorne einfach nicht
durchschaut hier etwas essbarem kleber
drauf damit den stab dazwischen wenn
dass ich oben bisschen rausgucken und
dann vorsichtig ankleben und schön
trocknen lassen dann einfach drauf
aufpassen dass die rückseite angeklebt
wird und nicht die vorderseite sonst
reißt worden
die blüten sind jetzt auch schon
getrocknet ihr könnt jetzt schon so
lassen oder ihr macht noch ein bisschen
pulver darauf das heißt ein bisschen
farbpulver und können sie so ein
bisschen schockieren
guckt euch nämlich sehr einfach passend
so jeder farbe in etwas dunkleres war
pulver lebensmittelfarbe und dann
einfach so ein bisschen am rand notieren
dann werden sie sich noch schöner
ich mache hier noch last minute blumen
und die mache ich jetzt komplett aus
blüten passte den blüten passende
trocknet wirklich super schnell und man
kann sich ganz ganz dünn ausrollen
ich mache jetzt ganz kleine blumen hier
kurz ausstechen und auch so ein
schaumbad legen wir nach dem austritt
einmal mit dem finger so drüber streift
dann gehen auch diese fussel hier
außenrum bewegt also dieses ausgefranste
geht weg dann habt ihr richtig schöne
glatte ausgesprochene blumen
[Musik]
und da nehme ich mir hier so ein ball
werkzeug und damit werden die ränder so
ein bisschen ausgedünnt also einfach aus
der mitte heraus in jedes platte rein
fahren und dadurch entsteht dieser 3d
effekt
[Musik]
dann noch ein paar perlen rein kleben
und dann sind die blüten auch schon
perfekt torte könnte jetzt zu lassen
oder ihr macht noch ein bisschen weiter
mit der dekra
das macht es hier einfach so ein
schmales band und clips oben an den rand
so haben sie den meisten töpfe außer mir
was du machen können und zwar darf so
oreo kekse nehmen auseinander drehen
wird es geht ist einfach so schön das
kann ich auch große auseinander drehen
und dann nämlich einfach die creme raus
die brauchen wir nämlich gleich nicht
gekommen nach richtigem essen
ja und dann hier in den mixer rein okay
okay
das darfst du machen und ich schneide
hierzu findet man das immer schön
gleichmäßig
[Musik]
jetzt schaue ich einfach dass die nato
bei der anderen art ist also hinten an
der torte und krebs jetzt einfach mit es
beim träger an
[Musik]
die torte die setzt sich später dann
einfach auf schönen unterteller guck mal
cool oder und die creme aber ich hätte
ein bisschen creme aufheben soll dann
ist nicht schlimm ich krieg auch jetzt
so die blüten angeklebt ich weiß nur
einfach deine euro
[Musik]
hier habe es nämlich so ist der kleinere
jetzt die kekse und vermischte dann mit
in kuchen krümmen
dann wird es noch richtig schöne
schwarze dunkle erde okay du darfst das
sieht doch aus wie blumenerde
jetzt wollen wir erst mal unten an den
rand zwischen erde und wenn bisher was
drüber geht ist auch nicht schlimm es
passiert beim töpfern und beim einsetzen
der pflanzen immer noch
[Musik]
mit ist eine bunte grüne punkte habt ihr
den hof und internet sind dann munter
mit ich kenne noch stiefmütterchen mira
du kennst dich amigos und was ist das
gelbe und das ist mir hier
wurde ich gerade von dem kleinen kind
geht ist ich muss wieder zurück in den
unterricht
ich muss euch jetzt gestehen hier oben
fehlt mir noch ein bisschen masse also
mache ich jetzt so ich nehme die creme
runter und ich habe mit den
abgeschnittenen paar vom kuchen
das vermisse ich jetzt miteinander und
dann setze ich als coop logan drauf dann
hab ich nur schöne form minister mars
damit die creme schon weiß wird der
bremer
[Musik]
so ist es gut und so setzte ich jetzt
hier die blumen drauf ich hätte halt
einfach schokocreme aufheben sollen ich
weiß ich habe sie zu früh verbraucht
jetzt nämlich ein bisschen schneller zum
kleben aber ihr könnt einfach die schoko
buttercreme nehmen
ganz einfach
[Musik]
so sind erde holz die liebesbotschaft
abnahme
[Musik]
perfekt die bekommt jetzt meine mama
bauer guck mal die typisch für dich
dankeschön
gefällt dir ja für meine mama viel liebe
nicht gießen
es war zu 100 prozent er hatte darf man
nicht lesen
der diplomat hat die erde gegessen hat
die erde hier wie schmeckte und wir
können sogar den topf essen aus marzipan
sondern mal anschneiden private vorsicht
hände weg
[Musik]
guck mal die oma mal probieren hat
messer weg wir essen zusammen mit oma
probieren das mal hier
ja ich gebe dir deine und man darf ja
schön saftig schmeckt sehr lecker
schokolade steckt oft sehr saftig und
aromatisch gab ja und sie erlag laut
sich einfach den riesigen berg an schoko
buttercreme papa schlecht ich bestimmt
auch wenn ihr auch eure mama überraschen
möchte mit einer blumen torte ist ein
lehrer hat freund sogar mir alle blumen
da hinten aufgezählt jahrzehnte und
narcisse und hier nun alles die kennt
sich da aus
wenn ihre mama auch mal überraschen
möchte dann backt doch gerne können sie
natürlich optisch so gestalten wie ihr
wollt die lieblingsblumen und eure mama
draufsetzen ist es bei dir halt bunt
gemacht einfach bunt gemischt hast du
auch noch lieblingsblumen sehr schön
also wenn ihr die torte nach mal schaut
einfach mal aufs eis - blog.de vorbei
postete auf instagram minute hast dort
macht man nächstes jahr wieder okay bis
zum nächsten mal nach england ist immer
so einfach zu begeistern
der flug ist lecker schmecker damit zwar
mira vom klavierunterricht ab
[Musik]